welcome to this video the first video
after a long break and I'm glad to be
back and finally settled in my new home
here the whole new phone has taken quite
quite some time and lots of effort I'm
really glad that this is finished only
have some slight technical things to
solve here but I'm ready to do videos
again and I'm of course taking a look at
the London chess classics which has just
been finished today with the final round
and probably you have seen the results
already but I go through the tournament
result quickly yeah basically you can
look at the the final table and group
this into three yeah three groups the
first group as the tournament winner
Magnus Carlsen not a big surprise he's
winning basically everything he plays
and second place Vladimir Kramnik they
both had an absolutely fantastic
tournament with cards and finishing on
plus 5 in an eight round tournament
which pounds up to the close to 3000
rating performance and Graham nikam
managed plus for unbeaten also and the
sum means 2939 rating performance so
also i'm absolutely out outstanding
result and then on third and fourth
place on Hikaru Nakamura and Michael
Adams quite a surprise he what he did
very badly in the last year's tournament
but made a really great comeback he
easily could have scored even more
points but at the end he had plus to the
same as the Nakamura played on his usual
fighting chess they both had 13 points
at the end this strange 3-point scoring
system where you can never tell what
people actually
in the tournament but ok it was plus two
for both players great result and yeah
then you have the third group so we had
two brilliant results two great results
and then the final five players um yeah
basically did very very badly well
champion Vichy are not at the bed
tournament he's out of form for quite
long while now surprisingly Aronian
played a bad tournament he finished on
minus one and he lost the first two
games so it was pretty much done after
two rounds and he could could slightly
recover with the win but he never really
um yeah managed to to get going then
judit polgár outside the bed tournament
with minus three year guess she won a
late game against the loop McShane you
also had a lousy tournament with lots of
losses and Gawain Jones the British
champion had um yeah lots of problems
with this in his first super tournament
she's very understandably never had this
kind of a position so but let's get you
to some chest content actually um and
I'm of course looking at tournament
winner magnus carlsen here against julie
program and what needs to be edited that
cards and broke the all-time elow record
of garry kasparov it's um heavily
discussed on the internet but ok it's a
suddenly nice to have this record
finally broken 13 years old and ok I
never doubted that that he would would
manage at some point and he will also
get much higher probably ok let's look
at this game hasn't opened a 1c form um
he mixes his opening moves he plays
everything so very tough for from a
pagar to prepare she answered c 59 f 396
yeah and here's the first interesting
moment in this game because cars in here
played deform this
move has been seen relatively rarely in
recent times um to my surprise really
because if you look at the alternatives
what white mostly place yes 93 but this
is now nowadays usually answered with
either five or g6 and white has
struggled recently too to demonstrate
something here those slow sad gums are
notoriously boring and very difficult to
get something with white there are some
ideas but it's not very dynamic and
cousins move from this d 4 is the much
more aggressive choice the red which
opens the center the only drawback is
that like can play exactly to set up
that program went form this e six set up
like some ideas to get some pressure
against the white center which usually
involves moves like you should to be
form or queen to be six depending on
what white is doing now for example if
white would would try to get going in
the center this Bishop before would
immediately put pressure on the center
so if I was a very rambles actually this
is a Sicilian now usually regions so you
move water the main move from is
probably g3 but after Queen B 6 Y term
has problems to to show something in
recent years which at the end led to
this move which cards now plate it's not
the most aggressive move but it has some
definite advantages I'm it prevents we
should be four of course and it asked
like okay what are you trying to do next
if black is playing a very very very
very slow fashion and doesn't do
anything much and what could go a form
let's say six or would play
and get this typical Murat see bind in
the center against a kind of Sicilian
Hedgehog formation and the game pagar
played Bishop c5 who see that something
similar happens she attacked them night
night retreated and Bishop e7 so black
has wasted a move with Bishop c5 and
Bishop e7 but has managed to dislodge
white knight from from default to be
three Raiders less aggressively placed
wider takes the center with deform
castles you should be too yeah v6 is so
illogical phien shadowing the bishop
yeah now we have a position which is
some very close to this typical Hedgehog
formation with black placing pawns on d
6 a-6 but one distinct difference is
that the night here on c6 is somewhat
strange to place normally this night
goes to d7 so um it is a slight problem
for black that this night is somewhat
somewhat misplaced on the other hand
white also has some problems this night
on b3 is not great it would certainly
need a move to get to a better square
and also white has played a 3 which is
also on probably ok but it sort of
determines White's future pawn structure
on the queenside as he was never really
able to play b3 to support the pawn so
mostly he will need to go before later
we see that in the game first of all
thousand plague Bishop f4 which is very
direct he simply intends to put this
Bishop on the six anthem this would
really a cramp black position so like
played these things to prevent this
Bishop t6 move rook see one was just gas
simply a useful strength strengthening
move black also rook c8 I think up to
this point it's a pretty a pretty normal
position I'm not much happening really
rookie one yam centralizing further and
95 gathers actually I'm I thought would
prepare this regrouping of the night 27
however judit polgár played it in a
slightly different way we see what what
happens 922 of course 95 was also
attacking the the pawn what's important
to notice that taking on e5 is it's just
a very serious positional mistake on
that wider shouldn't do after the wiki
recapture you could say okay black it's
got a double porn but look at those
pawns they control very very important
square ass on in the center and like has
also got two bishops so um this position
is very good for black also take note
that giving up the dark squared bishop
really weekend all dark squares so um
this is just just terrible it would be
okay if it will even night would put
take on e5 and transform this bone
structure but you cannot give up the
bishops for this okay of course cards
didn't do that he played 92 covering the
taxi from pawn and now lie to decide
which really surprised me a bit I was
really thinking black would do this
regrouping 9527 so a six and night night
back something like this let's say here
here and a six along these lines which
would set up the the classical head
shock formation like has lost a bit of
time with ninety five to seven but time
is not such a big issue in the head
shock so probably this would be a pretty
okay for black ok Knight to d7 and
Bishop e3 which actually is a novelty I
was surprised to see that it's that all
this has been played before I'm also
quite sure that cousin wasn't yeah and
it's a concrete preparation so the same
just playing the Sun over the board what
what has been played before pretty
interesting was before in Game one velia
against kashimo f king age eight Bishop
e3 and g5 this was what what gosh you've
played I think it's a pretty interesting
plan and actually a plan that yet tries
to make some sense of this night
placement this g5 move controls f4 so
that white cannot easy to play f-22 f4
to attack the night so this is a very
interesting positional concept which is
also well known in the Sicilian and
hedgehog positions so this was
interesting that's the the interesting
fact about the current game is after
Bishop e3 um yeah cards and intense f4
obviously but his son would quicken now
so I'm here it would have been
interesting to see if a g5 would be
playable um I think if you look at the
game maybe this was so was a very
critical moment where poor guy could
have gotten um at least somewhat more
young unbalanced position where black
maybe has got some some interesting
counter chances black sometimes really
can play King H a drupe g8 and and try
to get something on the G file some very
typical maneuver it's of course a little
bit risky but it's at least much more
yeah unclear than the game let's look at
what happened in the game she played
Quincy seven before yeah gphi this
constant idea but she didn't go for it
going to be eight yeah this is also
rather typical getting the Queen India
in the corner to take e4 but Q in the
corner is very very far away from the
king so need to be cautious with this a
four-night to g6
g3 and now you really have to ask said
what the hell is it is night doing on g6
it's just looking at pawns but the black
still is hell is solid it's not that
like is some much worse already rook e8
we should be a 30 white is just taking
space and strengthening the position
little moves like this are important we
should have to oops this one Bishop f-22
overprotective oh and prepare the Future
II 5 move yeah now black drop back the
night to f8 it's really not doing much
on one g6 this sir is clear Queen to e2
going to be eight is just a waiting game
rookie one and here we have a really
critical position where now judit polgár
commits them a pretty serious positional
mistake but it takes also Carlton's very
preterm precise way of playing to show
um that this is really such a such a bad
move she now played g6 and this is a
fairly typical move in headshot
positions but usually in those kind of
position the night is not on f8 and this
is the problem the f8 night simply has
no scope at all okay you can say it came
from g6 why is g6 such a great square
yeah let's see what happens wyd not
played the very typical movie 5 and we
seem pretty quickly why am this is a
problem this piece constellation on the
on the on the King side let's say just
for comparison sake like would have
played a move like h6 or any waiting
move for nothing if why then would play
e5 which is some
the typical way to to make progress and
then in this case you can have looked at
this kind of position here like for
example can play 96 the night cannot be
attacked with the f porn anymore and
really now those two nights do something
they attack our d5 and put some pressure
on this evolved on so on it's a useful
role that piece is playing if you look
at the game after g65 Bishop c6 it's not
much of a difference if black takes on
or why it takes on b7 it's always the
same structure let's look at the
structure why played Bishop before to
protect while what I should should show
however is like would take here you will
take here and we get the same structures
in the game that's not much of a
difference alright so this you played
Bishop c6 we should be formed group da
to take stakes and now they're three and
exactly this kind of position is the
problem um like not took this kind of
position is exactly the problem look at
this guy are these two nights those
nights f8 doesn't have a square as d7
yeah he's blocking the square and the
night on this happen also cannot go
anywhere and it's simply a terribly
passive position also in addition this
g6 move here has a weakened the this is
very very red f6 and h6 are very weak so
I'm also the King can be a problem this
position would be much better if the if
you could now play g62 g7 beclan
preparing a g6 but obviously this is not
possible in chess so now black has all
those holes h6 f6d six also yeah
it's really a really problematic to
defend this she played rook c8 getting
some play against see for at least an
hour 94 Quincy 7 and 9 22 protecting the
pawn if black would have played a 5
which is also an interesting move
attacking on before then White has a
very strong reply besides others yeah b5
has also not bad at all this is also
very strong move trying to attack f7 and
this is actually very difficult to
defend I'm also be five and 96 this kind
of stuff is also quite strong Black is
just terribly passive especially the
Knights yeah in the game Quincy 792 was
played 86 yeah because b5 was a threat
night f2m this introduces the idea of
not gon six amongst others you should g5
yeah trying to attack d 2 and therefore
increase the pressure on c4 but of
course I'm moving the bishop away as Sam
is a problematic decision yeah why just
played rook everyone now getting back to
a plan of a king side attack and she
took on detune and only five simply
based on the assumption to just grab
some material at least but them it
didn't really help here blog also could
consider take on c form should look at
this quickly and now energy form and
this now I'm it's terrible night to h6
and it crashes down on f7 black is
pretty much lost here
yeah she took only five but this is
answered by a quite similar thing night
on g4 attacking the Queen and also
aiming at f7 so this is a tricky
response at least chocolate one can give
this check and so take care and now the
poor move Queen f2 oops attacking on f8
of course the the poor night on f8 now
is the center of attack and the target
of an attack I'm gap Queen D for
exchanging Queens at least but White has
some yeah many good moves now Brooke
everyone would have been good what cars
are played also is strong and played c5
weakening out the back rank she took a
song takes and rooks e5 and now we see
that the back rank here sir is an issue
what should black do the rook is
attacked and if black gum that would
take here and white can simply recapture
and all those pieces are agile simply
terrible and the sea porn is so very
very strong so um yeah she decided to to
play rook to the eighth and not exchange
but this sum of course leads to two
rooks on the seventh and yeah I don't
know I have yet to see a game where in
this quite simplified position to looks
on the seventh yet did not win unless
you are you're made immediately or
something no I'm sorry to looks on the
seventh-ranked I usually win the game
and this is no exception so she gave
from couple of checks and here drop back
down with the idea of rook age five I'm
sorry rook age five
then white can simply retreat the night
and intend to go to f6 which would set
up something close to as oops wrong
position and in fact this is just what
happened look rook check cha cha so a
couple of spy checks and now black
doesn't have a check I'm sorry okay but
we're close to the end of the game rook
f7 and yeah the night thing and the rook
is saying so only move and now not f6
yeah and this is simply am the most
terrible piece set up that that is
possible against the king king cannot
move Knight cannot move and basically ya
black ass and zuke's one she can just
play meaningless moves like this and
white can simply improve yeah you're
black and played the desperate a five
that's not much else what can simply go
with the King towards the Queen side and
pick up pick up material so a5 takes
rokom a 8th and a 6 and now black
resigned there's simply no move you
cannot take a 6 because the fact capture
him and simply here if Black Knight
tries to get back the night you have
this interpose enter white as an extra
piece at the end and yeah like cannot
take a 6 they're simply a seven rugby
seven and Ruby a dent wins so I'm a very
very clean win here for Carlin um in
fact he said after the game that this
would be his best game in the tournament
okay he played some games after that but
I'm rather sure that he would yeah he
would still say that this would be the
cleanest win
he managed in this in this event so this
is somehow I'm why i chose the game I
also have to say that dumb the the guy
some who did the organization for lunch
as classic to the brilliant job of doing
online coverage there's some tons hours
of video coverage from the event with
life on comentarii spine by the players
by am a Grand Master's like an idol
short or Daniel King so great stuff if
you want some yeah something like chess
on TV then this is the closest you can
get go to London chest classics calm and
I'll just google it you you find the
front the homepage and then you also get
to the video archives it's very very
interesting to them to learn about the
players thoughts and ideas during the
game it's also quite quite funny
sometimes because it's its life and the
players sometimes I'm very candid about
what say they saw in the game or what
they didn't see end and whatever it's
sometimes also surprising what to what
they are what they are what they're
saying it's interesting ok I hope you
enjoyed them enjoyed this game i'm back
with videos and will do now updates
regularly probably not on a daily basis
i think i still have some things to do
here but there will be videos couple of
yeah let's say three four five videos a
week i'll manage not daily ones but yeah
stay tuned there will be new videos soon
yeah thanks and until next time